I gave gpt4 a budget of 100 and told it
to make as much money as possible you
are hustle gbt an entrepreneurial AI I
am your human counterpart I can act as a
liaison between you and the physical
world you have one hundred dollars and
your only goal is to turn that into as
much money as possible in the shortest
time possible without doing anything
illegal I will do everything you say and
keep you updated on our current cash
total no manual labor
it ends up suggesting
all right guys bang bang I've got Sam
here with me Sam you have become this
like connoisseur of the internet
everyone is like that guy's got tons of
ideas he's got crazy questions so I
thought a great place to start would
just be what is the craziest business
idea that you've attempted whether it
was successful or not like looking back
when you're like man that was pretty
crazy that we tried to build a business
around that
I'll tell you one that I did in college
and it's not that crazy but it's real
it's more stupid than than it's anything
so I one time I got poison ivy uh and
it's very coincidental I was trying to
like learn SEO and I got Poison Ivy and
I was like well I'll just pick a project
and I bought my poison ivy treatment.com
and I was like I'll just like make a
wall let's just see if I can rank for
like poison ivy stuff and I didn't know
how I was gonna do that and I did a
bunch of research and I found that there
was this thing called zanfill have you
ever heard of zanfil I have no it's like
it's like a poison ivy treatment but it
costs like 50 an ounce like you get like
half an ounce on Amazon for like 40
bucks and I started researching it
and I realized that in the comments
someone had said that zanfil is
basically just this
mechanic like you know how like when you
ever have you ever like worked on cars
or anything and they like use this
special like Degreaser on your hands
like when you're done like mechanics use
this like bead it's got like a bead it
feels like that stuff that like used to
get rid of blackheads on your face it's
got like a like a bead in it but someone
was like dude this is the same thing as
this thing called mean green and you can
get like a whole barrel of it for like
fifty dollars
obviously I was like bingo so I could
like and then I was like I need a name
so I created a product called it's juice
and
and it was basically just repackaged
mean green which was the same ingredient
as zanfil but it was like I would sell
it for like forty dollars it cost me
like a dollar
and it started making money like pretty
much right off the bat I just got like
someone on Fiverr to make a logo and I
started packaging it and then I realized
like a few months in even though it was
making like you know 500 000 a day I was
like
I'm like doing something serious I need
to like do this legally in the right way
and I don't want to sell poison ivy
treatment this is the stupidest thing
ever and so it was kind of like a
get rich quick scheme but I didn't
really get rich but I I figured
something out quickly but I yeah I used
to do like little like schemes like that
all the time in high school and college
and and like constantly how big does
something like that get like when you're
like okay I figured it out quickly are
we talking like ten dollars a day a
couple hundred dollars a day like how
quickly could you scale it
like two to three hundred dollars a day
in the first week okay and so yeah I do
things quickly I like it my whole shtick
is like when I get momentum and an idea
I have to act like within 24 hours
do you do that out of fear that if you
don't act then you'll never do it or do
you do it because you see like
offensively hey this is how you actually
build the momentum and make them
successful
because I'm OCD and I'm obsessed about
stuff and also early on in my life like
anytime I had an idea I had to do it so
I used to have I used to be afraid to
talk to girls and I like I was like from
now on if I see a girl I want to talk to
you I only have three seconds to like
make an introduction and so I just got
in this habit of like when you get an
idea you have to act immediately because
of the dopamine of seeing any type of
results is like addicting and you keep
going otherwise you're just like soft
and you never do anything all right so
you have like this skill set which I
like to think I have and a couple of
other people that we're friends with
have which is like you get these ideas
and if somebody else is like I should
sell poison ivy cream on the internet
they would not go about it the way that
you just described right they would not
think of like how do I find a way to get
better unit economics and then package
it and get the SEO uh and get to a
couple hundred dollars a day in in
Revenue but once you learn the skill set
you can pretty much apply this anywhere
right how do you pick up that skill set
did you just like figure it out did you
read a book did somebody tell you that
was like a mentor like how do you
acquire the skill set to basically build
these like online you know cash flow
machines
so I call this sounds cheesy but it's
funny I call it being like a manifest
Cowboy which is like I'm like addicted
to like manifesting things like if I
have an idea I have to do it and in my
head I tell myself like you're a [__]
you're soft you're never gonna pull this
off I love like that like stealth hate
it's very weird and I think it like
stems from I think I got mad at my
parents when I was a kid because like we
had a burnt out light bulb and like they
didn't it took them forever to replace
it and I'm like
screw that in my life I'm always gonna
fix things right away and create and act
right away and so I don't know I just
have been doing it since I was a kid
where I just like am OCD I just think
it's it stems from impulsiveness I think
that a lot of successful entrepreneurs
have a really nice balance of long-term
Vision but also being impulsive
when you've done these in the past are
there certain things you know not to do
everyone always wants to know what did
you do but like when you have a new idea
are there certain things now you're just
like okay I'll never do that again or
that specific type of approach doesn't
work
so once you get popular on the internet
and you have some success it does change
a little bit so like I don't know about
you you could tell me but when I have an
idea now I try not to talk about it
until it's like a little bit successful
because you know how people say like I
don't want people to copy my ideas well
when I was like a nobody and I still am
a bit a little bit of a Nobody But when
I was like when people just like would
dismiss me it was no big deal I would
just talk about everything constantly
and I'm like just watch I'll figure it
out somehow and it's no big deal now
when you have an audience you actually
and when you have like a smart audience
people do rip you off and so I don't
talk about I try not to talk about
things so we just launched Hampton I we
got it to multiple seven figures in
Revenue before we ever mentioned it on
the Pod or anything like that like I
don't talk about anything are you the
same way I am the same way but uh it's
for a different reason which is uh I'm
not worried so much about people trying
to take it and like run with it uh I end
up trying to find someone that I can
work with on it uh and usually what
happens is if you talk about it too much
the wrong people get attracted to it so
I try to find people who like I'm like
oh you could do like 10 different types
of ideas uh okay here's my idea like
you're like the right person and then I
tell them the idea rather than if you
put out the idea you get like all of the
industry experts on that you get all the
people who want to come from those
companies you know like actually those
are the wrong people I want the person
who like is coming at this from a
completely new perspective and they end
up being the right person well and
there's reputational risk so you don't
want to like put your brand behind
something that still sucks and then
there's uh just getting this sounds this
is first of all problem but like getting
too many customers early on
um and so there's things like that so
now I'm a little bit more thoughtful I
also Focus way more uh I don't just like
I I do a pretty good job like you you
have to like put out breadcrumbs and
like test things quickly but you can't
go all in I I'm a big fan of like not
going all in on like
um when I'm sorry when I do go all in on
something it's all in and you can't do
multiple things at once I'm a big fan of
focus when you were on my pod I was like
pop how do you balance all this stuff
and you're like well and you had a great
answer the first time I've ever heard
this answer you're like I don't balance
I'm only focused on one thing which is
building audience and then hiring really
good leaders and I was like oh that's
actually great but a lot a lot of people
don't Focus yeah so I was gonna say like
what is your thing that you do focus on
is it just one idea at a time is it a
skill of building internet companies
like how do you describe okay Sam is
focused right now on what is the thing
dude I plot so like so like I plot
hardcore and so like all right so before
I started the hustle I was plotting I
spent like 12 months I'm like all right
what are the economics of this like what
do I think they can become who's winning
in the market where's their weakness
like I plot pretty hardcore while
throwing little breadcrumbs out to like
test my hypothesis and then when I make
that decision I go all in and it's like
you know I I bet you this is like you
where people are like hey uh it's
Wednesday at 11 do you want to go like
hang out I'm like no dude I gotta work
like I have a job and so like when I go
all in it's like it's like it's like a
job you know it's like a nine to five
well it's usually longer than that but
it's like I'm all in and I focus on on
things so
um I plot hardcore so I've got like a
notion doc that has all of my notes on a
variety of different businesses and what
I what I've tend to do is I'll go and
find out who the bankers were that sold
the companies in the space and I'll just
cold call them and they'll like tell me
all types of details I'll call the CEOs
or the founders of a lot of these
companies I'll call ex-employees and I
use LinkedIn like crazy to find that and
I'll call them like where was the
weakness why did this suck I'll read
Glassdoor I'll look on Reddit I uh the
Apple reviews store I look at all this
stuff and I just plot and I have this
document that Maps out how different
things work and then I think about what
are my skill sets and interests and
which ones can this align to and which
one can actually kick ass in but I call
it plotting and so like
Sean my co-host Sean uh he just sold
milk Road uh his company and he was like
what should I do next and he was
immediately throwing ideas at me and I
was like dude just don't do anything
just give yourself 6 or 12 months no
timeline and just plot and be very
strategic about this because once you
have a little bit of audience getting
customers isn't that hard but making a
product that's good that you want to do
for 10 years is hard and so I call it
plotting I'm just like constantly
plotting you know what I mean I don't
know if you're like that though like I
think this idea of building something
that is sustainable and having the uh
both the benefit and the downside of an
audience uh is completely undiscussed so
having an audience everyone's like I
want an audience I want an audience one
it's very hard to test things and have
your name on it when you have an
audience because everyone expects it to
be the finished product but actually
most of the people who I think you and I
hang out with like we built our careers
on testing a whole bunch of different
things and then the thing that worked we
kind of like went all in as you
described uh you really can't do that
right now unless you like explicitly set
the expectation up front this is an
experiment I may shut this down I'm
going to try it for two weeks like you
almost have to like oversell the fact
that like you're not serious about it
which could dilute some of the results
as well because if you just are like Hey
we're launching this thing and then all
of a sudden two weeks later you like
shut it down most people think that like
that was your next company or that was
the next thing that you were going to do
and they put too much like seriousness
on it and it can actually work against
you if you do that five six seven times
before you find the thing do you see
that as well when uh yeah totally is
dude with Hampton I created a Google doc
and I just wrote out what it was and I
just sent it to like 50 friends and I
said uh I don't I don't sell friends I'm
just letting you know this thing is
going to exist if you want in let me
know and I just was curious what the
response was and that's how it started
and we got to many millions in sales
before we even
um or run rate before we even
like had a website and so now I I mean
I'm a big fan of doing things
hand-to-hand combat and I'll just get P
I call it hand-to-hand comment that's
what I call him like so there's times
where it's like Monday or uh Monday
Tuesday Wednesday no one is allowed to
talk to me because I'm on the phone
talking to people customers constantly
and I just like my it looks like my
calendar looks like it's got chicken pox
there's like little like marked out
times on every like little 30 minute
slots taken all over the calendar
basically 9 A.M to 9 p.m just talking to
customers and I don't even like building
a website until we get sales all right
so explain what Hampton is because I
think this is like a perfect uh anatomy
of like how to start a company in the
internet age today what was the big idea
that you had and I'm gonna guess
actually when you came up with the idea
but I want to First hear what the idea
is
so it's called Hampton joinhampton.com
it's
um so basically when I was running the
hustle Sean and I uh would meet once a
month it was me him our friend Sierra
you know Sierra I know who it is but I
don't know how to spend time
uh he has a big like PE firm and then
like Ryan Hoover would come a bunch of
times it was basically like six of us so
we would meet once a month and it was
like business group therapy like we
would like Express like I gotta lay
people off how do I do that or I'm
making good money what do I do with my
money or
I'm gonna sell my company how do I not
look desperate what's like a good
negotiating tactic like all these things
that like you couldn't really Google but
were kind of life-changing but you
couldn't like tell your employees
because you have to look strong in front
of them and you can't really tell like
your friends back home because they
don't know anything about like it's
embarrassing to talk about like certain
money or it could be like really silly
but important things like hey I want to
fly private how much does that cost how
do I do that like these things that you
don't want to tweet exactly and so we
did this thing and we all kind of like
sold our companies around the same time
and it was really successful but
when you're someone like me in Silicon
Valley I have a lot of like connections
and a lot of network uh a big Network
and it was easy to create that group and
so we created Hampton so we could uh
make uh like a highly vetted group for
other entrepreneurs and so what you do
is people apply they tell us about their
company their revenue their traction
their wants and desires and what all
that stuff we interview them their place
in a group of eight people that have
similar sized companies in similar
Industries they meet once a month with a
facilitator that guides it the
conversation and that's like the
business group therapy and then we have
like an online community that's popping
so like when the Silicon Valley Bank
stuff was going down like the day before
it happened people were like I'm hearing
rumors about this this stuff and like we
everyone got a a call and then people
took their money out and so anyway it's
kind of like
um almost like a YPO if you know what
that is it's like a YPO but for digital
first entrepreneurs
um most people you have to have at least
a million bucks in Revenue to join but
the average revenue size is like 30-ish
million
um and so but we have people from like a
million in Revenue like a 1 company with
a million this one lady named um Anya
she's got a company called rooted it's a
one-person meditation app that does a
million in Revenue all the way up to
publicly traded companies
so when you had I think it was the tiger
21 guy on the Pod I've never it was cool
right I've never heard you so excited
before and I remember thinking to myself
Sam is doing like the napkin math like
he's trying to figure out because you're
asking all these questions and I was
like he's like dissecting this business
at a level that uh he normally doesn't
do on the Pod uh and I don't know if you
had already kind of thought about
Hampton or uh you during that call were
like wow I should just do this for like
digital first entrepreneurs but I
remember specifically listening to that
episode and being like Oh man like Sam
loves that idea
I want to explain why I did that so I've
I've been thinking about this for years
I almost did this instead of the hustle
and then I always thought it could be
big but I didn't have the confidence
that I could pull it off and then we had
Trends you know we were an Advertiser
with you with Trends trends that Co and
I screwed that up but that had kind of
Hampton s qualities but I messed up
parts of it and I was like I need to get
this right and so I remember people like
chirping at me saying like of course you
can build like people always ask me and
I bet you get this all the time if you
had to start from zero what would you do
and I always say like well I would do
the same thing I would start email list
I would do the exact same thing it works
and they're like well of course you can
do it now because you have an audience
and I was like I'm gonna do this without
telling any of you about it to prove
that I can do it and so the reason why I
had tiger 21 on the Pod tiger 21 is a
like a it's like Hampton or YPO but for
wealthy people I think the average net
worth is like 40 million dollars or
something you have to have at least 20
million I think to get in and it's the
same thing where people like wealthy
people meet and they discuss private
stuff that you know you can't talk about
publicly and I remember thinking I'm
gonna interview this person in public so
everyone has the same information that I
have and I'm going to prove that I can
do it and so I did that a little bit out
of spite to prove that I could pull it
off it was definitely a chip in the chip
uh on the shoulder type of thing and
that guy was awesome
um what was his name uh Michael
um he didn't like me at first when I
interviewed him but then we got along
and uh yeah it's a good business all
right so when you get started uh you
have the idea walk me through like how
do you launch this thing and I know some
of the people who are in this uh they
are the highest quality people so how do
you go from like I have this idea I have
to execute immediately to okay now this
is to a point of success where I feel
comfortable putting my name on it
building a website like we're gonna go
do this
I created a Google doc that outlined
what it was and at the bottom of the
Google Doc it was a type form that says
if you're interested uh fill this out I
sent it to 50 people on Twitter like in
their DMs
and then uh I got up each on the phone
whoever clicked on the type form
I interviewed them and I by myself and
my partner Joe I have a partner Joe
Spicer he uh went and hired a bunch of
executive coaches and negotiated their
rates and together we created a
curriculum and then him and I would I
would we would record our Zoom
interviews that I did with all these
people and would say I think this person
would match with these other seven
people and we just by hand created these
groups and then I because I sold the
HubSpot I get for a free HubSpot account
and I did we just did it all on HubSpot
and we like emailed them a stripe link
we said all right pay and then and it
was very very very manual at first and
now we have hundreds of members and it
was mostly all manual and I started
working on it basically in the
summertime and we didn't have a website
until December
um and so it was all manual so as you
get started uh from my understanding is
you guys have raised no money you
literally if you texted me you said I'm
starting another company I would just be
like how much money do you want and I
think a lot of your friends would do the
same thing and I think most of our
friend group kind of just would like bet
on each other uh why not raise money
versus kind of go at a loan from an
economic standpoint
hey well there's a bunch of reasons and
I'll start with like some selfish
reasons one I think if you have a little
bit of cash and you could self-fund it I
think you can get wealthier owning
something I think
the lifestyle of just owning most of a
company that you can grow at your own
pace is significantly better uh not for
everyone and not in all cases like I
think an Uber wouldn't exist if they
didn't raise money so I understand that
but with this I just looked at which
businesses I think I could I could
self-finance
uh number two with a community-based
product
it's not like software we can just throw
tons of customers at the problem and it
just can scale like almost seamlessly
you just have back end issues so I
wanted to make sure that I wasn't forced
to grow it quickly
um but mainly it was just Freedom
um you know my partner Joe do you know
who Joe is I know he is yeah so Joe
Spicer he's my partner listen to this so
he sold his first company was 25 for
like 112 million dollars then he started
little things which was like a pet blog
it was like uh like almost like an
Upworthy style website he scaled that to
100 million in revenue and he got all of
his traffic from Facebook and then
Zuckerberg was like upward changing and
he had a turn sheet to sell the company
for over a hundred million dollars and
two weeks before closing date Zuck made
that change and his traffic tanked the
term she got pulled and the business
basically went out of business like uh
eight weeks later it was like it was
like a tragic like horrible thing so um
anyway I we we partnered and um wait
what was the question uh explain not
raising money
oh and uh we were sorry I was like Joe
so Joe and I were also part of a group
when I was running the hustle and we
would share everything with each other
we were sharing like I would share like
our net worth like I would say here's my
spreadsheet of my net worth let me see
yours let's like help each other like
figure out like what we want to do with
like allocation and whatever like we
were like or we were talking about
relationship problems that we're having
with spouses or girlfriends we would
talk about everything and it like
changed my life and so
uh when I I go Joe let's start a company
together but before we do let's write
out what we each want in life and so I
created a notion doc that says like what
does success look like how do you want
to spend your day
um what are your values and like we
aligned to where we both had freedom up
there but we're like we want to do
whatever the hell we want whenever the
hell we want we want to work hard but we
don't want Outsiders telling us what to
do and we said great we both align let's
start this together and so
that's why we just said all right well
it's self-funded how much money are we
each willing to risk and things like
that I mean you raised money for one of
your companies right
um but you have like three others or
something like that that you didn't
raise money for and I just think it's
if you have a big idea and you have a
machine that can turn one dollar into
five dollars I think you should fill up
that dump truck with money and just back
it into that machine but if you can do
that without raising money and use your
own Capital
um I think that that's ideal and that
was the situation that we were in I mean
what's your perspective on raising money
versus not raising money I I think you
and I think about it almost exactly the
same is uh the default is don't raise
the money uh especially if you have the
skill set the distribution the tools
that uh your disposal where you can get
Revenue very quickly uh then that
basically replaces fundraising right if
you're able to get to thousands of
dollars tens of thousands of dollars in
the first couple of months
um then you're able to basically use
those funds just as if you had raised
money but it's non-dilutive right
there's no better uh kind of uh you know
Capital pool to tap than customers in
order to uh to fund the growth of your
business
um but at the same time raising capital
I think there is a time and a place for
it and you know one there's some Capital
intensive businesses two is probably the
weaponization of capital like there's
somebody who worked at uh Uber who I
won't mention his name because I don't
know if he'd be okay with uh his name
being attached to it but he was like
yeah like Uber's greatest Advantage was
like they knew how to weaponized Capital
they could tap the capital markets they
could get that money and they were able
to use it in specific ways and in a
Marketplace business they had all sorts
of things where they were basically
subsidizing both sides so they would pay
drivers extra money they paid Riders
extra money and they could really use
that in a very methodical kind of math
driven way that would lead to liquidity
in the market which would lead to
revenue growth and then kind of could
help tap the capital markets again and
so like that business needed capital and
they were very good at implementing the
use of the capital
um and then the third thing is like
Acquisitions and so like I actually
believe what Andrew Wilkinson's done um
he has it in a holding company structure
but if you look at some of these other
uh organizations and companies there are
many public companies that literally all
of their growth over the last you know
10 15 years has just been Acquisitions
where they basically just grow through
acquisition and they sometimes grow uh
with those Acquisitions and they leave
them as standard own Brands sometimes
they buy them and they kind of tuck them
in and Rebrand them but if you're a
startup there is this huge opportunity
to buy things and kind of grow quicker
you got to be smart about it but a lot
of times the startup doesn't have enough
balance sheet Capital to do it and so
raising dilutive funding to be able to
go and buy things uh is a great way to
do it as well so it's like if you want
those specific outcomes or those
specific applications of the capital go
raise the money but everything else like
don't raise money because you own more
of it and I don't think there's anything
wrong with saying like hey the economic
incentive is for me not to raise the
capital
and Joe previously had a company called
uh pet flow which was like chewy before
Chewie came around it was a it was an
online pet store and he was like we're
not gonna we're gonna be profitable like
the whole time and he got creamed uh
because Chewie came along and they
raised all this money and their whole
thesis was like we can lose money for
the first year on certain customers and
we're going to provide such good service
that they come back and they were right
they won and it created a multi-billion
dollar exit but that isn't the case and
everything in every other business and
also
selling a company is well first of all
building a company that makes like a
substantial profit that's pretty hard
building a company that can sell that's
really really hard and actually getting
to the deal like the like when we sold
the hustle a week after we sold Brian
the CEO he got into a really bad
accident and nearly died and like that
could have like changed the outcome so
like there's all these things to sell a
company where like the stars need to
align it's very rare to sell a company
and then finally to sell a
venture-backed company where you need a
really large exit in order to make the
founder a substantial sum that's really
hard and so it gets harder and harder
and harder and I would think that I made
a significant amount amount more money
from my relatively small acquisition
because I owned most all the company
versus compared um to someone who raised
let's say 50 million dollars and even if
they sold for a billion dollars dude I
met a guy I know one guy who sold the
company for a billion dollars and he had
four partners and he made four million
bucks
um and so like getting like
a substantial amount of wealth wealth is
not my main thing while I'm starting
this company it's like I just love
adventure and dopamine but get but like
with the hustle it was wealth creation
and getting to like a substantial amount
of wealth creation by raising money
it's possible I just think the odds are
less so than creating a company that you
could own most of and sell for 30 or 40
or 50 million dollars still rare still
uncommon but I think it's easier
one of the questions uh that I know I've
told you uh that somebody asked at a
dinner which I thought was just a
fantastic question is they were like how
many of your friends actually got really
really rich by participating in
venture-backed Tech and that was defined
as 50 million liquid right or investable
assets correct like you have to Define
what success is right really really rich
and so uh for the purposes of the
conversation at dinner they said 50
million dollars liquid and what I think
we ended up coming to the conclusion of
was like you could have joined Facebook
as a relatively early employee but you
didn't need to be like the first 10 or
20 people and you probably still could
have made 50 million dollars on the IPO
and kind of the future growth of that
business there are a handful of other
businesses but really since like maybe
2014 or so there hasn't been that many
companies where the non-founders walked
away with 50 million liquid and so yes
you could start a company as a Founder
that's just not what most people are
going to do and so really what this
person was getting at was like is it
better to to go after the Venture
backable Tech startup you know founder
opportunity or is it easier to build
something that throws off you know five
million dollars of cash flow and just do
that for 10 years and then you end up
with 50 million dollars but it's a much
higher probability 50 million dollars
liquid than it would be if you basically
were illiquid for 10 years hoping for
that exit and it's a very interesting uh
question because you don't know what the
answer is but like people have different
risk profiles and so it sounds like for
you you've said hey look I know that I
can build companies and sell them but
now let me go do this build a cash flow
machine not necessarily be forced to
sell it because I've raised capital and
like let's just see how big it can get
yeah and I think there's a third option
so on the Pod we have this thing called
Sarah's list Sarah's name of my wife and
we um we made it because when she was
looking for a gig she was like I don't
want to start a company I don't like
that I like having a job I prefer that
and we were looking at so I was like
help drop like all right well let's
figure out what you want to do and I
think that there's a lot of wealth to be
created for an individual contributor
who joins like a series C startup so you
have like 250 to 500 to a thousand
employees
you get good like maternity paternity
leave you get good benefits you get very
competitive pay but the equity on that
company still has a 10x opportunity so
for example she joined Airbnb when it
was worth I forget 18 billion so it was
already very established but we were
wondering like could this become a 100
billion dollar company and we thought
yeah maybe so then if you get like some
equity in that like a competitive
package that can very quickly become
like a really good uh net worth for an
individual contributor who didn't take a
significant amount of risk and while
they worked hard along the way there
wasn't like the whole entire startup
grind of course I would argue that
that's a pretty boring life but there's
a lot of people that want that and you
may be like still even at 300 people you
have like big company problems that a
lot of people just don't have the
patience for but still I think it's like
a really really good
way to live life if you want like a
relatively chill life with a relatively
low risk and a decent upside but uh I
think that most people definitely should
start if they're going to start a
company and their main goal is well I
think not raising money is actually the
way to go for sure when you have that
conversation
what have what did the other people say
and were they Tech Founders who raised
VC uh there were a lot of tech Founders
and there's a little bit of like The
Grass Is Always Greener so like all the
tech Founders like oh man it'd be
amazing to like have a cash flow
business and not have to you know do the
board meeting and have to answer to my
investors and all of that uh also this
was happening during the big drawdown so
like there's all the pressures of uh uh
Tech compression and uh public market
stocks coming down whatever
um but I do think that there is uh this
belief that like now the tools are
available where you can actually build
pretty big businesses without needing to
raise tons of money which you should to
be equivalent to like you raise a lot of
money so you can have a lot of employees
those employees can do a lot of work
that work leads to a big business but
now given all the tools that are
available to you uh you can easily build
companies to 10 20 million dollars in
revenue and have like three or four
employees right and like even if you you
say okay like that sounds crazy if you
think of venture capital firms right or
Asset Management firms there are a lot
of of asset management firms that they
have you know I don't know 20 employees
or less and they manage a couple billion
dollars of uh assets which ends up
leading to tens of millions of dollars
of Revenue and like nobody thinks of
those as businesses because they think
of them as investors but like the
business of building an asset management
firm is like a pretty good Roi on the
number of employees for you know Revenue
per employee I guess and so like if you
then say okay well I don't want to do
asset management because I want to raise
money I don't know anybody you know that
would be an LP or whatever you can
almost go through every single industry
and there's somebody who has figured out
how to build a eight-figure revenue
business with maybe you know 10 or less
employees and it may not be something
you're interested in but I do think a
lot of tech Founders are like okay what
does that path look like because it is a
less pressure more freedom type path
and I'm actually going to make more
money like the other thing that a lot of
people don't talk about is most of these
Tech Founders are paying themselves like
between like I don't know 100 120 000 is
probably like the average salary that I
see once a company's hit like a series a
they're not paying themselves 500 Grand
and some Founders are starting out
they're paying themselves you know 60 to
80 grand and so like yeah that's a lot
of money to the average American but
there's you know public company CEOs
that get paid 25 million a year yeah
your CEO same entitled but like 25
million to 100K like that's a huge
difference and so like that same founder
to your point about you know joining an
Airbnb or one of these like serious
companies you probably could actually
make more cash just by going and getting
a job as an individual contributor than
you would as the founder of the company
dude I have a bunch of stories like I
have a friend who sold the company for
many many hundreds of millions of
dollars and I was with him when the wire
hit because we were celebrating and he
had 2 500 that's how much he had before
the deal closed and so like you know
yeah 2500 bucks that because he was like
I didn't pay myself anything and
um I just thought I was going to sell it
so I just kind of lived that way and uh
yeah I mean what are the economics so
let's say of an asset management company
first of all how hard is it to get to
like 500 million to a billion in assets
under management very hard yeah 500 to
500 million to a billion is the
equivalent of probably building like a
real uh you know 100 to 500 million
dollar company in like the tech world
right so then what what about 100
million in assets under management is
that like achievable if you work for 10
years for 10 years yes
and so on 100 million dollar fund let's
say that there's one partner what what
would their income be each year I mean
there's two percent management fee has
two million bucks
right and then now they have they have
expenses so they've got to be able to uh
you know pay the back office they've
probably got to pay for uh legal fees
like there's a bunch of things that go
in that but for most Venture funds they
should be able to take as Top Line you
know kind of take-home pay somewhere
into like 1.25 to 1.5 million dollars if
there's a two percent management fee and
they're the only employee
um and then you pay taxes and so like
you know take home could be depending on
where you live 750 to a million bucks
and that's consistent it's not like
whatever three symptoms do where it's
like you know we gotta like make
something sometimes in order to like
make it work I mean that's a good
business what other companies do you
know of and you can like hide the the
name of the company and like be vague
about it but do you know other
businesses that are doing like 10 like
10 million plus in cash flow for the
owner that only have 20 employees and
what type of businesses are those
so I definitely don't want to say the
name of the company nor the industry
it's in because I'm actively looking to
try to buy a company in the space
um but there are uh brokerage businesses
in like traditional Industries so like
if you go into
um like industrial spaces and things
like that uh there's the same mechanism
as Uber like if you really think of what
Uber is it is a asset light Marketplace
so it simply has on one side drivers on
the other side it has writers and a
writer requests a ride and then they
match you with a driver the driver comes
and picks you up and Uber gets paid a
fee for basically brokering that
transaction and it's grown into this
multi-billion Dollar business uh but
that's like super sexy consumer you know
whatever there are tons of brokerage
businesses throughout like the
industrial space where let's say that
you're like hey I am uh on a
construction site and I need uh bricks
or I need aluminum right or maybe I'm a
uh a warehouse and I need some sort of
materials or whatever rather than you go
Source it yourself like you call these
brokerage businesses and a lot of times
they're doing the exact same thing that
Uber does in that uh ride sharing
transaction but they do it with like
call centers right like you literally
call and somebody answers the phones
like hey what do you need and you're
like I need you know uh I don't know 500
bricks you're like okay hold on and they
like go Source it from some brick uh
maker and then they like match you those
businesses tend to be incredibly high
margin and so then it's just a question
of like how big do they get but I've
looked at a bunch of them and like
they're doing 50 plus million in Revenue
with 20 or less employees that's what my
dad does with onions by the way wait
really I swear to God yeah he's so like
he'll uh you know he will work with like
Walmart or White Castle or like you know
I don't entirely know all of his clients
but like like some fast food chain or
something and they're like you know we
need a million dollars worth of onions
or we need 20 truckloads of onions uh
and then he'll call Farmers and he'll go
and buy them and then sell it and take a
little fee for connecting it and it's
just him and one other guy and they made
a great living
um but yeah he's an onion broker so
literally this is I I think you can take
that idea of the onion broker or the
industrial broker whatever and you can
just pull it across every single
industry and in every industry There's
an opportunity to do this and one of the
the mechanisms as to where to identify
uh like that could be a big business is
when you have some sort of national
provider so for example Walmart they
have stores all over the country they
don't want to go figure out like what is
the Onion Farm in Kansas then what's the
Onion Farm in Missouri what's the Onion
Farm in you know Minnesota or whatever
they just want to call the same number
or call the same company every time and
be like hey we need this many onions in
this location and so whenever you can
match like National reach with local
production There's an opportunity for
these brokerage type firms and the
beauty of it is like you don't really
need much like you basically need a
phone and you need to network your way
in get the contract start fulfilling
orders as The Brokerage and you
immediately start to drive revenue and
so it's like a very very simple business
uh that is industry agnostic that if you
can figure out how to launch it uh you
can make a lot of money who is your like
business hero like who do you emulate
who do you when you think about what you
want to become in the next five or ten
years and you think this person's
nailing it or I want a life like that
who do you think about
well I think that there's different
people for different parts of that
question right uh who I think has been
the smartest when it comes why did you
laugh by the way when I ask you that
because one of the people I'm gonna say
people will uh will get all worked up
over
um there's people who have done things
in business that I really respect and I
think are still even though they're well
known are still drastically
underestimated and then there's people
who have like a lifestyle that I think
is something to emulate unfortunately uh
as with most things in life the extremes
are like hard to bring together so the
people who uh maybe the most impressive
business-wise may not have the most
Balanced Life and so you kind of have to
choose like elon's probably the best
example everyone wants to like build
wealth but would you trade being the
richest guy in the world if you slept on
the factory floor
hell no I would never want his life
right like well forget his life just in
general just like if you had a really
shitty personal life but had all the
money like that doesn't seem very fun
right
no I I wouldn't trade spots with him at
all all right so on the business side uh
let's do uh we'll each go so I'll say
one person on the business side then you
say one person business I'll say one
person personal you say one person
personal uh on the business side I still
think that Peter Thiel is drastically
underestimated for what he's been able
to do and it's mainly because he's been
able to make so many contrarian bets
along the way and be right more often
than he's wrong but also he's been able
to do it in a very smart economic way
what I mean by that is like just by
creating PayPal and putting those shares
in his IRA
he ended up creating billions of dollars
of wealth that deferred the taxes and so
basically what he did to The Listener is
I think what he did was he invested five
hundred thousand dollars into Facebook
from his Ira is that correct uh I don't
know about that investment but when he
created PayPal which
um uh came before the Facebook uh
investment he actually bought the
initial shares so like if you was like
which is like uh which a lot of people
don't know when you start a a
corporation I don't think an LLC does
this or maybe does but in S Corp and a C
Corp I think it does when you start a
company you the owner literally has to
write a check it's typically for like a
hundred bucks it's like a thousand it's
under a thousand dollars I think at the
hustle it was like 89 I write a check
and I send it to the IRS and that is
when I bought my shares
um and that's like the cost basis and
that's what he did with PayPal yes but
rather than do it out of his personal
bank account he did it with money that
was in the ira so the quote-unquote
shares that he owned in the company
actually were his Ira uh ownership and
so what happened is when they sold the
business that those shares were not
taxed because they were inside of the
IRA and so you can't spend that right he
can't spend it but he can continue to
compound it until he turns like 60 years
old right when he can actually access
that money and so you take a loan can
you take a loan on your IRA I don't know
the answer to that but I'm sure if you
can people have figured out how to do it
um and so it's just like one of the
interesting parts of this is like
how much do you have to think in the
future like how Forward Thinking and
long-term thinking do you have to be to
be in your 20s and say I am going to
make a decision now that will set me up
for 40 years in advance which is hard
it's hard right that's like very like
whenever I meet like 21 year old kids
who like have these startups and they're
saying these big Visions I'm like wow
you're that's like pretty bold and you
me I meet people like this and I was not
like that yeah I mean I think most
people are like hey I'm trying to get to
Friday right let alone like 40 years
from now so so I think that um and then
also I just want that blooming onion
baby I want that that blooming onion and
Outback I'm not thinking about IRAs bro
I just need to get that blooming onion
to the softball game and I'm cream
cheese exactly
um and so the last thing on Teal I think
is uh he has created a number of
businesses uh and also continued to
invest in Great Deals
um but the most impressive part of all
that is just like he has consistently
been one of the best selectors of talent
and he's found all of these great
operators great thinkers you know really
contrarian type people that it's not
like oh he got lucky once or twice right
it's like very obvious that he has an
ability to identify and select talent
that I think most of us are envious of
and so if there's one skill in business
that I personally wish uh if I had to
like lose every skill and just have one
I actually think that's the most
important skill is just like be able to
identify and select Talent consistently
better than everyone else and if you do
that like you always have a shot to
build something successful do you uh
what do you think his personal life is
like well balanced or no I don't know
um I I tend to think that uh you know
everyone has pros and cons and so like
if you were even if I was to ask you if
you asked me if you asked you know uh
Peter till or anybody else like they're
probably harsher on their own life than
other people are uh because it's really
easy to be like oh uh this sucks or this
sucks and everyone else was like yeah
man but like I wish that I had that
right and so I it it uh it's a weird
thing who's who's your business person
so I like a lot of historical figures so
I uh there's a book called Titan it's
about John Rockefeller and I really like
him he um he lied famously one time
about creating like a monopoly but
besides that he was like mostly always
honest when it came to business he was
like a handshake type of guy and was
like pretty pretty honest and he also
knew when to bail and so he basically
resigned when he was in his early 40s
and had CEOs run the companies and so I
admire people who
uh like
I admire people who know when to get in
and get out and let other people do the
stuff and not take a lot of the
publicity so I like John Rockefeller we
had Rob Dyrdek on the Pod have you
talked to Rob Dyrdek I've never talked
to him but uh the fantasy factories
legendary
dude he was dialed in went to his life
and I felt like he had a really really
good way of like looking at life he was
super dialed in so I'm really uh I
really like him business-wise
um do you know a guy named have you
heard of CB insights yes fantastic
episode
yes I love him so this guy's name's uh
is Anan so Anan is a is he's a Hampton
member and I've so I've gotten gnome
through that and basically CB insights
they've only raised maybe 10 million
dollars in funding they're close to they
could be over I'm not sure but like nine
figures a year in revenue and CB
insights is basically like
um it's a database product so what he
does is he loves to find messy data
publicly available data it makes just
makes it really clean and easy to read
and the reason I like him is he's been
patient so he's been growing this really
steadily for 10 years CB insights has an
awesome newsletter that I love reading
but besides that they're really low key
so I love you know I love people
business-wise who are a bit of the
opposite of me you know what do they say
what does Lil Wayne say he goes Real G's
travel in silence like there's a real G
the Real G's moving silence like lasagna
yeah yeah yeah so I love people like
that who are just like quietly doing
stuff and you know there's another uh I
always think of this song you know the
David feels good to be a gangster by
ghetto ghetto boys he goes you know real
real gangsters don't flex nuts because
real gangsters know they got them so I
just I love people like that and he's
one of those guys who he just doesn't
talk about it he doesn't make a fuss he
tweets funny stuff but he's not
outrageous he's pretty professional but
has having a good time and he's just
quietly doing stuff and I love people
that just shut up and they do stuff you
know I have a big mouth and so sometimes
I admire people who don't because I'm
like man I wish I could have a little
bit more self-control and be like that
so I like a non he's someone I really
really admire he just shuts up and he
does work and you don't hear from him
but he's just killing it and uh so I
really like people like that
um because of Hampton I've met all these
people and I can't reveal their names
but I've met like five or ten people who
they have like these software businesses
that do 20 million in revenue and
they're based out of like Kentucky or
Idaho and you'll talk to them and they
kind of look a little schleppy and they
just look like normal guys you don't
have no idea but like you know I'll like
talk to them about cars and they're like
yeah I got I have one of those Bentleys
um because like I I I'll talk to some
members I'm like oh I love cars what do
you like because I like this this and
this and I'm like oh what are you guys
like oh I have one of those Ferraris I
have one of this thing and they just
have cool stuff because they love it but
they don't like brag about it and they
don't flex and so I love people like
that Anon it's not like a fancy car guy
or anything like that but quietly
building this monster business and he
doesn't talk about it and I really
admire that when we wanted to for him to
come on our pod he didn't really want to
go on at first he like just wasn't after
it he just like he was like no man I
like just chilling and uh I kind of had
to like ask him a couple times to join
so anyway I like people like that and
then the last person is darmesh the
founder of uh HubSpot so darmesh uh
shots his name he started HubSpot and
business-wise he's kind of my hero
because he had a company I forget what
it's called I think it might have been a
consultancy he sold it I don't remember
how much he sold it for but he probably
made 10 or 15 million dollars and that
was like in the early 2000s so that was
probably enough money where he was like
I don't have to do anything anymore but
he went to MIT uh and he was like I sold
the company I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
get a degree at MIT which is odd and at
MIT he met this guy who was a
salesperson for a software company and
that guy was Brian and they put together
a school presentation on this idea they
have for CRM and that is what HubSpot
became darmesh funded the company with
five hundred thousand dollars so he uh
you know owned a lot of the company and
he said I've got one rule Brian you've
got to be the CEO and no one ever
reports to me but I'll hack away and
I'll build great stuff that the company
loves and that's what he's done and he's
always been a hacker so he built a
HubSpot so hubspot's like give or take a
20 billion dollar company depending on
the day but he still has side projects
so have you seen his project called
wordplay I've seen a couple of the ones
that he's done wordplay is pretty cool
and then I think he just launched
spotchat.ai or something yes he loves he
loves spot chat so wordplay is a game
that he made he goes I wanted to teach
my son how to code so we worked together
on this game it's like uh what's that
thing called Wordle it was like it's
like Wordle but there's like not on you
can play as much as you want and I say
uh I said well how big is that and he
goes oh and like by month three we had
like three or four million people using
it I was like what how much money does
that make he goes well I let my son run
ads for one month just so we could
understand monetization and it made 90
000 uh and we just donated the money and
we have this thing and it's just like
killing it and I'm like why'd you do
this he goes I just got to keep my
skills sharp and I just love I love
hacking on projects and so he does that
in his free time
um and I just think that someone like
that who again he's just kind of he's
just a g he doesn't Flex too hard and he
just builds stuff because he loves it
and he won't tell you about it unless I
ask him and so I like that he also built
spot uh what's it called uh chat spot
chat which is like this add-on that
HubSpot is gonna like incorporate where
you could like use Ai and talk to
HubSpot like it's a person and it'll do
stuff for you so anyway he's actually
building it and coding it and so I love
that I love people like him and if I
asked him to come on the Pod he'll be
like maybe next month like he's just not
like interested in bragging about all of
his accomplishments so part of what I
love about these types of people is like
they're tinkerers right there they just
want to kind of do these little things
and figure out if it works or not and I
tend to find that uh there's two
questions I ask in interviews now
um that very quickly uh help me
understand a person better uh and it
doesn't matter what they answer with
it's like what is the uh type of answer
is really important it's like one is
like talk about something that you built
recently that has nothing to do with
your day job and usually what you find
is like most people have to think for a
second what it is but it's not always
Tech like it could just be like oh I
went in the garage and like I you know I
fixed uh my car or I had one guy come on
the podcast uh do you know this guy John
Finkel he has a a newsletter called uh
books and biceps
no but that's awesome tell me more I'm
in all right yeah biceps all right books
and biceps and so he's got his home gym
but I saw him tweeting one day and he
kept referring to the Flex factory and I
was like what the hell is the flex pack
yes and it's his home gym and he was
like growing up I always wanted to have
a home gym it's like I built one I named
it the Flex factory he put up like all
the stuff on the wall I'm like it's
awesome right it's like every like
washed up middle-aged man's dream but he
is like that on steroids and he's
killing the game and so he uh if I was
to interview him be like hey talk about
something you're proud of that you built
like not related to your day job if he
just started to describe the Flex
factory I'd be like got it like check
the box like you're great you know how
to build cool [__] like you get it um
and then the second one is uh I always
ask them like what podcast do you listen
to or what books have you read recently
and and again less because I want to
actually like oh this book is good this
book is bad but it's like you quickly
understand the type of person they are
by what they're reading and then if you
even take it further and be like what's
one thing you agreed with in the book
and one thing you disagreed with you
very quickly can kind of wash away all
the [__] and it's like hey this
person can think critically or not and
so I've had a number of people who I'm
like hey what did you disagree with in
that book and they're like nothing
and I'm like you read you know 300 pages
and you disagreed with nothing and
they're like then they kind of think
about it and they'll like eventually you
know kind of answer but there is this
like skill to tinkering there's this
skill to like critically thinking and I
think the internet some people end up
getting washed away and it ends up like
getting worse and they don't Tinker they
don't think critically but then the
internet can also help you do it more
and somebody like darmesh is a perfect
example where like he is like an
All-Star of the internet because he
likes to Tinker and keep those skills
sharp right
yeah totally when I at the hustle I used
to have this phrase where I used to say
you come work here I want you to let
your freak flag fly
and so I would look for like oddballs
and like weirdos and I love those types
of people because the world wants you to
be vanilla and if I could find someone
who isn't vanilla and like it's just
quirky and odd and they have to be good
at their job but I want to surround
myself with like I love a freak Show
that's what I want I want like weirdos
and like
um I would always surround myself with
the with those types of people and
typically they they tend to be pretty
good because they're quirky and that
quirkiness can carry over to like the
except that that like that it's that
type of eccentricity is like kissing
cousins with like person who's willing
to take risks you know what I mean so
like it's like very related what about
um why do you think why do you think
that those people are so good work-wise
so they are they compensating for like
the quirkiness or like what is it that
uh makes them great uh people to hire
they're just original thinkers usually
you know like a lot of people like what
I don't like is if someone tells me like
they read all these business books and
I'm like oh dude fart like you're just
so lame like I I can't I don't wanna
like you're just gonna regurgitate the
same thing over and over again you're
not gonna come to the table with
anything unique and you're gonna be
fearful all the time so I want people
who aren't fearful I think when you hire
when you have employees at a company
like there's this weird thing at a
company where even though a person knows
that the right thing is to do option A
they'll do option b because I don't want
to be embarrassed and look stupid and
it's really hard to find people and I
think it's actually intrinsic I think
it's built in for the people who are
willing to take option A even if it
isn't like uh
um like the safe like
that risk-taking genetic
factor or whatever it is I think that
you either have it sometimes or you
don't I think it's really hard to like
get people to change how do you know
that somebody's a authentic freak like
they didn't just read some book and
they're or they watch this podcast like
oh Sam likes freaks like I'm gonna like
be a weirdo in the interview so he
thinks I'm a freak like how do you make
sure in the interview that you can tease
out like who's real who's not so if some
people are like like I'll have people
like you you joked with me where you
like said let's [__] and like I said
that to Anon and like I'll say to like
my friends but if someone is like
obnoxious uh like in an interview with
me I think oh you're just you're just
lame I could tell that's not authentic
and even if it is you don't you got to
learn how to like be polite and [__]
like that so I don't like people that
like you can tell who's turning it on so
I do the same thing as you I ask you I
go what content do you read every
morning and they'll say like newspapers
and stuff I'd be like no no tell me like
who do you follow on Instagram and what
subreddits you go to every morning and
why and like I'll I'll get all types of
information I also use this tactic that
I created called I asked him about the
bottom fourth of the resume so meaning
in the bottom fourth of resume that's
where you put we went to college and
like the clubs that you joined and if
they say they're part of a club or
something or if they say they studied
philosophy I don't really care about
philosophy but I'll say like what's the
what's the most interesting class that
you took and why and if they can do a
good job of explaining and having
passion about something that's
relatively obscure then I think like all
right this person's ovens ovens burnt
this person's oven Burns hot and they
have got some horsepower there and
they're kind of interesting so basically
if you can entertain me in an interview
about what you read each morning or
about what you studied in college then
I'm interested if you can't tell me with
passion what you spent four years and a
hundred thousand dollars studying then
you're probably a loser what is your
personal operating system like you have
so many different things going on you're
always kind of tinkering with things
you're running Hampton like what are the
tools you use do you use certain things
for email calendar note taking like what
are those things that make you so
productive
I use this notepad right here
I write stuff I just use a notepad a pen
I don't have an assistant I use Gmail
notion and that's it I have like a it's
pretty effective but also like I get
overwhelmed pretty easily do you have an
assistant I do now for years I was like
Pride that I didn't have one but
eventually I got one and uh um I will
say that it's a full time full time uh
but across all of the businesses so only
one person across everything uh and
there's two advantages that I realized
after the fact one is uh I never screw
up or forget the big things but like
tons and tons of like little things that
are actually not very important from
like my day to day but maybe super
important in blocking somebody else
those things getting your car registered
or something like that like little
things like that yeah so like I don't
really do a lot of the personal stuff
like I don't I don't ask uh her to do
that stuff but it's more so like let's
say that you and I uh work together uh
you have a business that we are helping
with capital Distribution on and you
have a list of five things that you're
like hey we got to get this done this
week right and one of the things is
something that is uh requires
coordination with an external Source
around like scheduling something or
sending an email to me that may not be
the most important thing because this is
the fifth most important thing on your
list for the week right but like I'm
obsessive I want to make sure I get it
done and so rather than let it fall
through the cracks like it's like that
is her one of her jobs is to make sure
that we have a list of every single
thing we need to get done this week and
we don't finish the week until we have
that stuff uh um kind of done the second
thing has been really helpful with is uh
she creates a report at the end of the
week that audits the calendar and
basically says here's how you spent your
time and so it allows for like week to
week self-correcting of like hey socks
right that's that's a painful that's a
painful exercise I I love doing it
because all it tells me is like I've I
know what's the most important thing
right now and then I can look and see in
a quantifiable way how did I spend my
time and if the most important thing is
like company a but I spent all my time
with companies see like there's a
mismatch I got to get back on track
right is your calendar booked from block
to block uh for the most part yes I try
really hard to push everything between
ten and four because I write in the
morning and then I try to like just go
back to back and squeeze everything into
a six hour period calls meetings all
that stuff
um but like You Gotta Be You gotta pay
attention if that's what you're gonna do
you got to pay attention to where you're
spending your time because it's very
easy just to say yes to a lot of stuff
so she helps with that
um and then there's actually one other
piece that is uh uh super encouraging
she understands context around a bunch
of questions people have for me that I'm
not needed to answer because she's there
so like in some way people now they just
ask her the questions
right and so like you got to really have
a high degree of trust with this person
for them to be able to do that but like
I don't need to answer every single
question that people have especially
internally so having her as a go-to
rather than wait for me for an hour or
two hours to get done doing a podcast
with you all of a sudden they can just
ask her and maybe eighty percent of
their requests she can answer for them
Point them in the right direction get
them you know the document they need
whatever and then for the 20 she can't
hey it's Gotta Wait and I'll just do it
when we get done why don't that's your
life wait sorry what are we gonna say I
was gonna say why don't you have one
what what is what is the the reasoning
um a little bit is pride like you like
you were saying and a little bit of it
is I've always felt uncomfortable having
an assistant it just feels I don't know
I it feels weird right like asking
people certain to do certain things I
don't know I've been uncomfortable with
it but I need I do need to get that is
your person in America or overseas in
the office with me every day in Miami
yeah I think I should do that I think
that's awesome I don't know why I think
it's just Pride I
um
let's see I tried a virtual assistant
they were great at some things they were
horrible at other things and so uh what
I eventually decided was like it was
worth the additional money to have
somebody in person that I could meet
with that could attend meetings that uh
could do all the things that like are
now available in person uh that a
virtual assistant can't do but I do know
uh like there's one CEO I know uh he's
very much like performance oriented he
has a american-based uh assistant but
they're remote
and lights out like he one time was
driving uh with his wife on uh like a uh
like a Vespa Scooter like almost like a
motorcycle thing and they got a flat
tire he literally like pulled over to
the side of the road they were late to
this dinner he got an Uber he basically
messaged her and was like hey this is
what happened here's where the bike is
like help and went to the dinner ended
up getting there a few minutes late but
not as bad and like even though the
assistant was remote was still able to
coordinate and kind of do everything so
I think it's like a lot of not just
having one but also having the right
person for what you need is a is a big
piece of it who's your um hero
personally like uh you said
business-wise what was the personal side
so I tend to think that the people who
are uh best optimize on the personal
side is like not hey I have this like
perfect life it's hey I am doing the
thing that makes me happy and right
sometimes like the external vision of
like what the perfect life is actually
would be super uh shitty life experience
like I go to dinner sometimes and
there's people there and from the
outside they have everything that quote
unquote like people want right they have
well they have what appears to be a
great marriage they have this great job
what you know company they built
whatever and then you talk to them and
you're like you are a hollowed-out soul
like you are dead inside and they know
it they just haven't like fully uh kind
of confessed that to themselves and it's
like I don't want that life and so when
I think about uh kind of the
quote-unquote uh personal Heroes it's
all of my friends who don't give a [__]
when people externally think about uh
them and it's just the people who are
happy and so I'll tell you a story that
uh uh I think kind of highlights this I
was driving
um with uh my wife in the car we're uh
driving down the street and we stopped
at a red light and she goes what are you
thinking about because I was like
looking out the window and I just like
was honest like maybe mistake number one
and there was a guy who was edging you
know the grass uh like by the curb and I
was like I don't know why but I just
thought like that guy has such a great
life like like he had like he doesn't
give a [__] what is happening on Twitter
or this or that or like hey like he is
going and he's doing something with
physical labor which is a hard life but
it's also something where it's like the
stresses of it are much more physical
than they are mental and emotional and
like all of those types of things and I
remember thinking that like at some
point in your career you have to make
like a fork in the road decision very
few people have both physical and mental
uh stress at work and so
that path is not one that I chose
but like it's a different path and when
things are going wrong on the path you
choose sometimes you look at the other
path you're like man that is like a
simpler life but vice versa that guy
probably is like looking at the car and
he's like man that guy's life is simple
and so like how much of it is
expectations versus reality
and I I don't know so like what's your
answer
you uh well I'll give you two the first
is Laird Hamilton do you know who Lair
hit oh yes yes Legend Laird Hamilton is
the surfer guy he like looks like if you
think of like what a surfer 80s hunk
would look like he looks like that you
know he looks like a Ken doll he's just
like this buff dude you know he's
probably close to 60 now so he doesn't
look like as buff as he used to but he's
this guy who basically helped Pioneer
big wave surfing and then eventually he
created this thing called uh
layered creamer I think it's called I
forget what it's called but it's like a
coffee creamer it's like a big business
you know tens of millions whatever but
he has a person running the company but
he said uh they have this thing where if
so he basically has his house in Malibu
with like a pool that he works out in
and all these people come to his house
to work out and he's on the beach but he
has this thing where everyone knows that
if a wave if like the the forecast says
that the waves are going to be above 20
feet automatically you can't talk to him
and he will not talk to you or have
meetings because he has a rule that if
the waves get above 20 feet he goes
surfing so it doesn't matter like where
he is in the world if it's above 20 feet
near his place he flies back and he goes
he goes we're going surfing that's my
rule so I like that uh because he like
lives life to his own standard and also
his wife is uh like they're Partners in
a lot of his businesses and like they're
they're truly a partnership so I value
that but another one
do you know Sam corcos from levels yes
I'm an investor in levels same same same
um I uh they um so there's a guy named
Sam he's got this company called levels
and it's basically you put this glucose
monitoring thing in your arm and it
tells you about your blood this guy is
as freak as they come so I hung out with
him one time I hung out with him one
time and he was with his girlfriend
um and she just made a joke uh because I
said like uh
I don't remember we were just talking
about like you know spouse stuff and he
was like oh Sam always gets mad at me
because he says I take too long to pack
but that's only because he just has that
bag and I look at Sam I go wait what is
she saying and he goes this bag that I'm
wearing and it was like a drawstring bag
like you know those things that you'd
play soccer or football with he goes
this bag and what's in this bag right
now as well as the clothing that I own
or that I'm wearing I don't own anything
else I go what do you mean he goes this
pair of jeans I've got one I've got a
jacket in this bag I have this white
T-shirt I have my shoes I've got my
computer my computer charger my cell
phone and my cell phone charger and my
toothbrush and that is all I own and I
was like are you serious he goes yeah
I've been doing this for like 10 years I
just don't like owning stuff it stresses
me out I'm like what if you have to go
to a funeral it goes like go to a thrift
store I buy a suit afterwards I bring it
back uh and I was like are you kidding
me he goes yeah I just don't like things
it doesn't make me happy and I live
nomadically and I've been doing this for
years and years and Sam is interesting
because this actually might be public to
everyone I don't know if it's investor
only but he writes these in-depth
investor reports and I invested a small
amount of money early on in their in
their round and in a way I feel like the
value that I've gotten from the investor
reports is worth the amount of money
that I put in the company he they're
really they're literally like novels
they're like
they must be like five thousand or ten
thousand words every single month he
sends one and he goes here's an update
in the business and he tracks everything
I was like why do you do that he's like
this is just how I like to run the
company and I and I hire people who
enjoy doing it this way it's just easy
for us to be on top of things and I love
it what do you think about his investor
updates they're crazy right I think
they're amazing and uh
he knows I call it the warning system
right because he he has such great
understanding of what's going on in the
business that he will know something is
wrong before most CEOs do and so like it
takes a lot of time care attention to
detail like you know all the things that
go into uh writing that type of report
but if you have the early warning system
you probably are better off for the type
of business he runs than not doing it
but also I think there's a lot of
businesses where like that would be
Overkill and people would be like this
is absolutely insane why are we spending
so much time on doing it so I think a
lot about like is that the culture of
the business or not and he specifically
you know even told you right he hires
people who like that is what they want
to do but did you do that with the
hustle like did you have like super
crazy you know long uh investor updates
where you had every single metric laid
out
no I didn't I I but I was pretty good at
sending updates and keeping things
updated but why I ran it much more
simply so every Monday we would have a
meeting we called it the numbers meeting
and for the first 10 or uh three three
years of the company we would meet as a
company and we're like did our email
list grow by three percent or not
this past week and why and it was the
whole presentation was just one and so
we would pick one number one metric and
then eventually we we picked two
opposing metrics so it'd be like uh new
customers and then like renewal rate
because you don't want to go just after
one because you can manipulate that to
her long term but eventually but it was
basically just like did the email list
grow by three percent or not and I
wanted to grow it by three percent every
single week because Paul Graham said if
you can grow something by three percent
that like it ends up like I think I
don't remember what the math is but
that's like 12 or uh 12 times growth per
year or something like crazy he's like
if you do three percent that's
considered good so I just said all right
we're gonna Grow Up by three percent
every single month
um and we're just gonna have a meeting
every month and each person is going to
explain how they contributed to making
us grow by that rate and so I was like
maniacal about that and uh I think that
was really effective
if you had a email today which a lot of
the people who listen have some version
of email whether it's their company
email or personal email they send it's a
business they're trying to build
whatever how would you grow it
so the hustle has like close to 3.5
million readers a day now so it's pretty
big when I sold it we had a little less
than 2 million
and 3.5 like that's hard to Fathom it's
because like I just have a little like a
side hobby email list of 10 000 and I
could see that that like makes a lot of
money I mean your email list is what
what do you have 250 000 maybe 150 000
uh 230 000 yeah and that can make like a
substantial amount of money and so with
a 3.5 or 3.5 million email list we could
probably made
I don't know maybe 40 or 50 million a
year just off email advertising like you
can make a lot of money and so I look at
it now I'm like I can't believe how big
it is but if I had to grow so our first
100 000 customers or 100 000 users came
in year one and that was from me
blogging I would just write these like
crazy blog posts and I would post them
on Reddit and it would get traffic and
three percent of people would sign up
and that's how we got it and I would do
that the same way now but I would start
probably on Twitter so instead of a Blog
I would do Twitter but I would still do
part of the blog but then what a lot of
people do nowadays so me and uh the skin
and morning Brew we were all building
our businesses separately but we were
all building at the same time and we all
learned that you could do paid marketing
once you understood how much your CAC
was and how much your LTV was and so
back then we were able to acquire
customers for two dollars nowadays
people are still doing that except
they're doing it early on with like me
and morning Brew in the skin we got to
like hundreds of thousands of customers
hundreds of thousands of users then we
did paid marketing now people are making
the mistake of doing that way early on
and I think that that's a huge mistake
well if I had to do it
because you have like a leaky bucket
most likely like pay like paid customers
can be good but they're not going to be
as good as an organic customer they're
going to churn out sooner and so and
also paid marketing will give you a
false signal that you're doing good the
whole point about an email list is
attention and so like the value of an
email list is like if you had to make it
an equation it would be something like
number of subscribers multiplied by the
amount that they're engaged and the
amount that you have uh influence over
them multiplied by the spending power
so a ten thousand
uh Fortune 500 CEOs who own software
companies or something like 10 000
software company Founders or let's do 10
000 ctOS of software companies that have
at least a thousand employees is going
to be significantly more valuable I
would bet than 500 000 State home moms
you know things like that and so the
buying power matters and also the amount
that you're able to uh influence you're
able to have over them and you know you
have influence over them when you tell
them to buy something or you recommend a
book or a product or you say I'm hosting
a Meetup come and hang out with me uh
that's really how you know you have
influence but a lot of times what people
do when they're starting their
newsletters they think oh well my list
is growing therefore I have influence
where it's like no dude you can just
throw money at that problem I'll get you
subscribers you need subscribers dude
I'll get you subscribers you know it's
like Big Lebowski you need a tow man
I'll get you a tow like getting some
getting subscribers like it's not hard
when you're just paying money to do it
the problem is you're is you're throwing
them into a leaky bucket where people
don't actually love your content and so
a lot of times people who create news
newsletters they don't think of
themselves as like they'll they'll think
of themselves as like growth acquisition
uh experts not creating content and it's
like dude you got to get the content
first not the growth the growth is
actually significantly easier what's
harder is getting someone to subscribe
to your daily email and have them to
want to stay for three or four years and
so I think you shouldn't do any paid
marketing until you have like 20 30 40
000 people uh and that's like a really
big ballpark but that's like if you're
doing a somewhat mass-produced email
that's around maybe when you'd be ready
to uh do paid marketing is it do you do
paid marketing we do no paid marketing
and uh only have used Twitter really to
uh to grow uh the email and um it's
great because it's super organic really
high open rates you know all the things
that you want uh it's also incredibly
frustrating if you don't do paid because
you it naturally just hit a limit right
like it doesn't matter how many uh how
much you push it like if you only have
um a certain Twitter audience like
eventually you just saturate them right
and so like if if we wanted to turn it
into a full-on business then yes paid
marketing is the way that you scale past
like the organic growth
um but but uh but it's difficult uh
let's talk a little bit about Agora uh
because I think Agora is like this like
really interesting uh business have I
talked to you about that no we've never
talked about it but I know that you
probably have opinions about this
um and so for those that don't know
Agora is like a newsletter company
um that really from my understanding
doesn't just do advertising on the
newsletters it's really a way for them
to do distribution for video courses
training programs like a bunch of things
in the background my understanding is
that they do close up billion dollars in
annual revenue really more okay explain
explain uh what your thoughts are so
Agora is a company started by this guy
named Bill Bonner out of Baltimore and
he started it maybe in the 80s so before
the internet was really popular it was
like newsletters like they would mail it
to you and Bill Bonner is like this
libertarian sometimes it's a lot of
times it's politically charged but it's
a financial like publication and so I'll
tell you where to invest
it's kind of like Motley Fool but uh has
like a political slant
and he started it and it was doing fine
and he had it for like 10 or 20 years
and it was like slowly after a while got
up to like 10 20 million dollars a year
in Revenue after like 15 years then he
some of his employees wanted to Branch
off and do their own thing and he goes
well hey instead of starting your own
thing why don't you go start a new
publication for me and we'll do some
type of equity split and so now Agora is
a company that owns probably 20 or 30
different Publications they do north of
a billion dollars in revenue and they've
helped Pioneer like a lot of direct
marketing stuff and a lot of stuff that
they do is Shady but you can learn from
it and here's what they do and I
actually have a screenshot of their
financials I can send it to you and what
they do is um like I said dude I do
research I talk to the people who work
there
um and I'll send it to you like so
usually what they do is they have a free
newsletter or a free webinar something
like that
and it's about like um
um like picking stocks or something like
that then they have a hundred dollar
product uh which is like better picks
then they have a two thousand dollar
product and they make all of their money
on what they call the back end that two
thousand dollar product and now they've
gotten so big that they sell like
supplements and they sell everything and
they've been sued a ton of times they
recently got sued by the FTC because
they did two things one they claimed
that they wrote a book that can help you
cure diabetes like naturally which is
[__] so they got sued for that and
they got people to pay money for the
book and they also created this thing
called the Republican tax where they
like said that like Nancy Pelosi is
going to come after you because you're a
Republican and tax you more and they
like would write a direct response email
where it looked like it was uh Nancy
Pelosi wrote someone an email the
recipient clicked reply all to the Agora
email list that said hey everyone Nancy
just sent me this email we can't let her
get this done and here's why and they
would write really long form articles
and what and for people who are in
marketing what they're famous for is
long-form copywriting direct response
copywriting and we're basically talking
a website with nothing on it but 4 000
words in a really small link at the very
bottom that says buy now and those pages
convert beautifully I don't agree with
everything they say but the numbers show
that they are like the best performing
things and so this guy basically Bill
Bonner you can look him up he's a
billionaire and all along doing this
newsletter he started investing in
Baltimore real estate and he owns
multiple skyscrapers in Baltimore or if
you Google Bill Bonner France his wife
owns literally palaces or what do they
call them in France I forget what they
call it these like Estates and they own
all of these like Estates in France uh
what do they what's like an old palace
in France called uh like a villa or
something like that but they like own
all of these and they do like interviews
with like home and garden and all these
stuff of like his wife like showing off
he's like they're literally like uh like
like old they look like Old Stone
castles and so anyway he's like this
kind of like an eccentric crazy person
but this company does collectively like
one to two billion a year in revenue and
like three billion a year in profit and
he owns all of it did it's incredible
what people can do if uh they have a lot
of time right 30 40 years and they keep
at it and perfect something like again
dude and copywriting the copywriting on
this [__] is like crazy and you read it
and you think who reads this and then
you start kind of like digging into the
story and you're like uh this is a page
Turner this is uh like I'm into this
it's like it's pretty wild how important
is copywriting still today given that uh
you know there's the rise of AI it's the
internet everyone's got slick websites
like I know that you're a big uh
copyright is uh drastically under
indexed on but like explain what should
people do if they want to get better at
it
I read your article on sub stack about
uh what was the title the one you sent
me the other day
um where the body in crisis uh yeah
dude I read that article and I didn't go
to bed last night till 3am I've been
reading all your stuff like it kept me
up all night and like it's gonna I'm
Gonna Make You know like a pretty
substantial financial decision based off
of your article like please don't do
that please don't do that what I mean is
like it's spurred it like you like got
me thinking like your point of that
article wasn't wasn't to make me act it
was to make me think a little bit but
like it spurred me to action and that's
an example of copywriting where your
little Rinky Dink sub stack article with
no design just beautiful words I told
you do you have this one analogy called
where you said uh bodies are floating up
to the water and then you had this other
line talking about Lenin you said um
you know with the economy nothing can
happen for decades and then a decade can
happen in a few hours or a few days and
like those phrases made me act and made
me feel and my point of this is that
as we get more text-based which we
already are you know you text people you
use online dating you use Twitter uh
blogging email whatever copywriting in
my opinion is the most important skill
because
copywriting isn't just about using words
that sound cool copywriting is
understanding what motivates people and
then uh using the written word or spoken
word using words to get them to do what
you want them to do so if you want them
if you're Martin Luther King you want
people to be uh treat one another nicer
so you're going to use I have a dream
and like we all remember that it's like
understanding what motivates people if
you want someone to buy something you're
gonna you're gonna use certain language
if you want someone to go on a date with
you you're going to use certain language
like it's understanding the words to use
that meets the person needs to get them
to do what you want them to do and so in
that regard when if we phrase
copywriting that way in my opinion it's
the most important skill because you're
going to recruit people to join your
company you're going to want to meet a
spouse you're going to want to uh
convince someone to donate to your
charity you're gonna we're always trying
to sell something and I so I think
copywriting is the most important thing
the most in the best way you're a great
copywriter I don't even know if you like
have ever like tried to get good but you
are very good but the best and most
effective way is this thing called
copywork have you ever heard a copy no
it's that so copywork is just uh way of
learning that isn't popular anymore but
it was and so if I'm going to teach you
how to play the piano I'm not going to
sit you at the piano and teach you a
little bit of theory and say write a
song I'm going to ask you to play Happy
Birthday and then Jingle Bells and then
I'm gonna give you like eventually some
maybe a little Jazz and then like once
you get good we'll play like an Elton
John song like you're just gonna copy
other people and you're gonna do that
for a year or even a couple months and
you're gonna start doing oh wow these
chords usually go together like my
favorite artists tend to use this
structure I'm just gonna like steal a
little bit from this person a little bit
from this person a little bit from this
person now I've got my own art and
that's how copy that's what copy work is
and so literally what you do is you get
writing that you love it can be like 100
S Thompson used to do this with books
um Judd Apatow the famous director with
Seth Rogen he did this with like
Saturday Night Live scripts
um I do this with really famous uh copy
um sales letters you literally just
print it out and you get a pen and paper
and you just sit there and you write it
by hand and you do that every day for a
little bit of time and you'll get better
at writing it's like one of the best
techniques that I know to learn how to
write and it's been effective for years
and years and years and there's actually
science behind it that shows that like
when you write it it imprints in your
brain and you start feeling the texture
and the flow and that's why we're so
good at learning instruments learning
instrument it's not very hard like if
you just give it enough time you will
get at least okay
um and so anyway that's the most
effective way to learn how to write so I
advocate that everyone actually does
this because
like once I learn how to do a be uh be a
copywriter my online dating sure got a
lot better uh you know what I mean like
I was able to like effectively
communicate to like my friends what I do
for work I could uh like I could like I
could do anything and so now I've made a
substantial amount of money with just
like a I can just use like a if if you
just give me a plain like web page where
all I can use is words and then you give
some other person like a traditional
like New York designer type who wears
common project shoes and have them like
design the fanciest slickish page I will
bet a lot of money that I can create a
website that collects more in sales or
conversions than that person can because
copywriting is I think the most
important thing when it comes to like
getting a sale or uh a conversion have
you seen along these lines um there's a
guy on Twitter I forget his name but he
went to chat gpt4 and he was like you
are now my co-pilot I want to give you
100 and your job is to make as much
money as possible I will do whatever you
tell me to do with my 100 have you seen
this thread no but that's crazy what
happened dude he uh so he's on like day
seven I think now uh I'm gonna have to
try it so
um let me look real quick uh
and by the way I don't know people are
asking me are copywriter and content
people going to be needed even with
artificial intelligence I feel uncertain
about my answer for that but in one
regard I could be like maybe if
everything's automated then maybe
there's more room for like Craftsman but
on the other hand I'm like
[__] these AI people are like really
good like they're like the best all
right ready so this is what this guy's
doing his name is Jackson great house
fall and he tweeted out I gave GPT for a
budget of 100 and told it to make as
much money as possible I'm acting as
it's human liaison buying anything it
says to do you think it'll be able to
make smart Investments and build an
online business follow along 100 000
likes on the uh original and so his
instruction the exact one was you are
hustle GPT an entrepreneurial AI I am
your human counterpart I can act as a
liaison between you and the physical
world you have 100 and your only goal is
to turn that into as much money as
possible in the shortest time possible
without doing anything illegal I will do
everything you say and keep you updated
on our current cash total no manual
labor
and so what happened what was the first
idea long story short is uh
uh it ends up suggesting to set up an
affiliate marketing site making content
around eco-friendly and sustainable
living products it initially suggests
a.com uh that was too expensive for the
100 budget so they settled on green
gadgetguru.com amazing the guy buys the
uh thing and then they take a prompt
they put it in Dolly they make the logo
uh you know he's like going through the
whole thing long story short is as he's
doing this the audience starts getting
big like there's 100 000 likes on the
first tweet so he then starts to ask
permission of GPT hey do you think that
we should like run ads to the website or
maybe we should take some advertising
dollars to put people who want to
advertise sustainable products into the
Twitter thread that we are doing around
building this business and so he starts
driving Revenue initially by literally
just getting people dming him and he
starts posting their ads in his Twitter
thread as he's doing it how much
revenues yeah so uh cash at total after
day one 163 dollars no way
right so he basically got a 100 initial
investment then uh he somebody put a
hundred dollars in as an investor right
like he like all these people started
like dming them stuff so he starts to
kind of gather money whether it's
through investors whether it's through
Revenue whatever but long story short is
if we fast forward to uh the most recent
day he is now uh let's see he's now at
uh when it started zero blog post zero
Revenue zero members on Discord he now
has one blog post 130 in revenue and
almost 2 000 people in a Discord as of
two hours ago and seven days ago when he
started this the uh gbt was telling them
all these different things to do and so
the major update yesterday was that
after launching uh they now have green
Ovation market so green Ovation like
innovation in green put together Market
it helps people find eco-friendly
products and they made their first sale
on Sunday and so now what they're seeing
is that they also have dream you later
dream you later which is a short
Adventure Game co-created by humans and
gpt4 and then they now own meow matters
which is a guide to cat Essentials tips
and tales to cater to your perfect
companion
then they have Atlas Adventures which
fuels your wonderlust like a passport
for World Discovery embark on a journey
across continents and time and so these
are all the people inside of their
Discord that are building all these
different things
Furry Friends Supply Company blah blah
whatever and so the reason why that
becomes fascinating is like this dude
literally is just told artificial
intelligence like tell me how to make
money and like regardless of whether he
makes 60 bucks ten thousand dollars or
like a gazillion dollars I tend to think
that like the AI is better than some
portion of entrepreneurs oh my God like
I don't know if it's like okay AI is
better than one percent of all
entrepreneurs right now or like 20
percent
but it's not hard to see like 10 years
from now like you'll literally just be
like hey AI here's my money like make me
more money and I want a cash flowing
business that does a million dollars a
year in profit like figure it out and it
just does it I'm like writing all this
down this is the craziest thing I've
seen in a long time this is wild so then
what's your take on how this is going to
impact like content creation I mean it's
basically you and I like this is our job
yeah content creation is like pretty
simple but I don't know if it's to the
place where like you can easily just
like create something and then just
publish like I still think you need some
human editing whether it's you me or
like actual editors
um but I do think that this idea of like
asking this like super computer for
instructions if you said to it hey tell
me how to build a uh blog with a million
readers a month
I bet you we could show you step by step
exactly how to do that and as you give
it more information it just simply says
okay this is working this isn't working
try this here's something else whatever
like this is going to be a productivity
tool it's going to be like a co-pilot
and so if it increases the odds of you
accomplishing some of this stuff maybe
you don't actually get to a million
visitors a month but like damn if it can
help you get to a hundred thousand which
is one tenth of your goal like why is
everyone not gonna go do this do you use
any of this stuff for your newsletter
you're not right you don't write daily
anymore right you don't now you're only
doing like a couple times a week so
whenever you have an idea so I still
pretty much write daily every once in a
while I skip if I don't have an idea but
but uh I try to write daily if I can
um I actually didn't tell anyone this uh
like two weeks ago when the day the day
after gbt4 came out I used it to it
probably wrote like
sixty percent of the newsletter right so
here's what happened is like I knew that
I like I had in my head like here's what
I want to write and so I wrote like the
intro paragraph and then I like asked it
a question it gave me like three or four
paragraph answer and then I really had
to go in and kind of like edit and
massage it to make it uh kind of make
sense and then I asked it a second
question it gave me another like three
paragraphs uh and then like those two
things weren't connected so I had to put
some like kind of uh connecting
information in but when it was all said
and done like it probably provided about
60 of like the answers to the questions
I was having plus like the basics of
what the the paragraph structure was and
all I kept thinking to myself was like
oh this is like having like a a research
team right or like a ghost writer almost
to some degree but I couldn't but but
what what was the pro so you went to
just chat whatever website you just went
to the normal
um open AI site yeah and I just was like
you know uh I forget what I wrote about
that day but like let's just say it was
like uh I don't know banking crisis
right if I just simply was like uh what
are the three uh largest bank failures
in the United States before uh 2020.
and they told me what that is that is
right like it's like Googling on
steroids because you could Google that
probably click on a link find like some
list of a bunch of bank failures figure
out which the three are take those ideas
then go back to you know the uh uh CMS
and then like write out the three
paragraphs but chat CBT like does the
research and then like basically gives
you kind of An Unfinished product in
three or four paragraphs so it saved a
bunch of time of like searching and then
like transcribing basically the
information you just found on Google
into the into the text
um and so like that's fascinating
because could you compress let's say it
takes you an hour and a half to write a
newsletter maybe you still have to spend
30 minutes but if you can press it and
then also uh are we all just going to
become editors right like how much
writing in the future if this becomes
really powerful is going to be like I
sit down I have an empty CMS box and
like I start from scratch versus like
maybe you throw a couple of prompts and
it gives you a bunch of text and then
you more become like an editor putting
it all together like it's fascinating to
think about
I um by the way tell your clip guy you
you just the way you told that story
about this Jackson Guy Jackson fall
there's your there's your million view
clip that was a good clip but I um the
other day I was having to write
something and I did an okay job but I
was like you know a lot of times when
you're writing stuff
you like keep thinking about like five
different ways to say it you're like I'm
just in this little box and so I have
you heard of um this book called How to
get rich by Felix Dennis dude I am uh
20 pages in I heard you say this on a
podcast I bought the book and I was
gonna wait to talk to you about it until
after I read it so I haven't read it yet
I'm like 20 pages in but go ahead and
tell uh what you want to say I think
it's like the best book on business ever
but the way that he writes it's
beautiful his language is the best it's
the per it's like I call it Elite cheeky
it's like he's got this like weird like
Elite Vibe but at the same time he's
like an everyday guy and he's got this
like English cheekiness about him the
way that I describe Felix Dennis it's
like Richard Branson and the Rolling
Stones had a baby and that's like him
dude that's a great description
literally uh the word that kept coming
to to mind as I was reading the first
you know 20 Pages or so was like
enthralling it was just like literally
like oh my God like this is amazing but
you know what else I envisioned it's
like you ever meet like a really really
rich like maybe some guy in his 50s or
60s and you're just like dude literally
me and that guy are like the same guy
like he's like smoking a cigar chilling
just like
if people saw this side of you at home
they would never think you're that
person like out in public and you
realize like who that person is like
that to me is as I've been reading the
the first couple Pages this dude is
literally just like a regular guy and
it's amazing and I'll give the
background a second on who he is but he
um I if you just Google like his book
PDF you can find it for free and I took
the whole book and I uploaded it to to
AI or to chat gbd3 and I said um rewrite
my sales page as if you're Felix Dennis
and it rewrote it and I go great do it
again do it again do it again and I
found like little bits and pieces where
I'm like okay cool that's a beautiful
line stealing that one that's a
beautiful line so basically this guy his
name is Felix Dennis he created uh Maxim
magazine that's probably what he's most
known for it's not even popular anymore
but he made a lot of money but he also
created this thing called micro
Warehouse which went public in the 90s
maybe the 80s uh for multi-billions he
died uh probably 10 years ago when he
was worth like 750 million dollars he
basically is famous because he says he's
probably spent this is his words I spent
100 million dollars on track and [__]
uh so basically he was addicted like for
like a 10 period a 10-year period of his
life he loved crack uh he got addicted
to crack cocaine he um was single his
whole life and he just he's like I just
love paying for sex I just like it just
that's just how I like to roll that's my
thing and so he spent all of his money
that way and he asked this book called
How to get rich and the best part about
this book
is he just tells you like the truth
because he's like I'm already rich I
don't care if you buy this book or not
but here's the here's what I think but
there's two graphs in that book that are
kind of life-changing there's a graph
that says here's my definition of rich
and he says like poor somewhat poor
you're only doing okay you're wealthy
now you're really seriously rich and he
like has these like drafts and he has
categories so he's like zero to like
twenty thousand dollars and then it gets
to like you know a million to like eight
million liquid you're this and he like
names these categories of like liquid
wealth versus private uh company wealth
and then he also says if I could do it
all over again I would have earned 30
million dollars by the time I was 35 or
tried as hard as I could to get to
whatever I could by the age of 35 and
then just retired because like a punch
drunk boxer I retired too late and I
have so many Rico rats that I didn't get
to spend time with doing this thing this
thing that thing and he writes it in
this the best prose I've ever seen it's
just beautiful language It's a Wonderful
book we talked about an iPod and it was
like
the thousandth most popular book in the
business category and then so many
people bought it it went like number two
uh and so like people love this book
it's so good I'm so happy you're reading
it dude it literally uh I think even
says in the beginning in the in the
version that I have where it's like you
know like why should you read this book
he basically is like I don't care if you
read the book like I'm just writing the
book and then he's like uh did I write
the book yes I am writing every single
word myself like he's so self-aware as
well of like the irony of a rich guy
writing how to get rich and people just
thinking that it's like this the guru
like I made my money teaching other
people how to get rich right and he's
like that is not what I did I actually
had real businesses and now I'm just
gonna do this to help all of you so I'm
excited to finish the book and see uh
what I learned from do you think that
the AI stuff is going to end up killing
jobs or do you think that it is going to
end up actually creating more jobs
yeah it's definitely going to kill a
bunch of them at Hampton we're trying to
use it for customer service stuff
um I mean are you
well
what do you think I mean I think you
know like usually with me is when I see
this stuff frankly I'm afraid so I like
bury my head in sand and I just like
hope I'm like oh it's gonna go away I
hope like if I just go under the covers
they'll go away I'm afraid I think that
it's definitely not there yet but the
rate of which it's growing it's like you
know like did you ever like play Oculus
before yes like whenever I put and
played a few games in Oculus it was very
clear there was two things that were
clear
one it's not there yet
number two it will get there and when it
does it will change the world and I
remember thinking that when I put Oculus
on I was like all right it's not it's
this is still prototype but I can see
the future I just I just looked 10 years
into the future and that's a little bit
how when I use AI That's how I feel it's
it's not there it will be there it's
coming and that's kind of how I feel do
you want to know the data point that uh
has me convinced uh it's over for a
bunch of these businesses that existed
before
um is every young person I talk to that
is like related to Tech so they either
work at a tech company uh they're trying
to start a company whatever like kind of
like 25 and below
they all are using this product and not
like you and I like kind of like fooling
around like oh let me put up this
paragraph and like see what it does like
I have to get work done let me go do
this and a friend of mine he met with uh
a 16 year old a 17 year old he met at
like some sports thing
um and he asked them and they're like oh
we use it for our homework
like it's like basically for you and I
Google
they're already using this as a Bonafide
product it's not a prototype it's not a
maybe it'll be here one day it's like
they were just given the superpower and
now they're using it it's crazy and I
actually think there was this great
article I think it was the New York
Times I forget
but there's some reporter uh on the
ground in San Francisco and I remember
when I lived in San Francisco starting
in like 2012 it felt magical like I
remember there would be all these like
they weren't House part they weren't
like a party but we would all be in a
house like working on computers and like
toying around or someone would be like
dude I used to work in this place called
the founders dojo and it was oh I know
that was like my home for a while you
heard Founder's Dojo yes and so Dave the
guy who ran it he was he had a a pool
company like uh it was just like a it
was a company that was like a lead gen
couple for pool I don't know probably
made 800 Grand a year 500 profit he had
this office that he spent five thousand
for and he had like 10 deaths and he
would let freaks like me go and work
there
dude I would be like listen to the story
so there's this one guy these two guys
uh who had it was Chris and uh Chris and
Raj they had a company called the worst
drug dot TV and they were built they
were Building Technology that would
display high quality gifs really quickly
so it was basically a full screen GIF in
HD and you would click space bar or you
could type in a word and like the search
functionality was like instantaneous
that was the whole technology geeky
stuff
but they created a way that would
aggregate the most popular gifs
throughout the day and you could just
click space bar and instantly it would
refresh and that was the technology
turns out the most popular gifs on the
web are super hardcore porn and he would
have we had these massive high def
screens because they were working on it
and it was just the hardest core porn
all the time and we got desensitized to
it and we would be staring he'd be like
hey guys check this out look how uh like
you know look at look at her you know
whatever you could see how and we were
like oh yeah that's really it wasn't
even it was like clinical we weren't
even like it wasn't even about the sex
it was like oh wow that's really high
def you can really you know see what
they're doing you could see inside of
her like it was like horrible stuff and
one time I had like a uh the founder of
Pandora he was gonna come speak at one
of our events and you want to do like a
pre-talk talk with me to figure out what
we're gonna talk about it was him and
his PR people came in and they walked
into the office and we were all just
gathered around this computer and he's
like now I changed the technology so
when I click like uh the word p it
autofills with like the most popular
stuff and it does instantly like clicks
it we're like oh wow and they walk into
the office and they're like hey guys
they're like oh hey come check this out
look at this technology Raj Bill and
like you like forget about how weird it
is but it was like
it was like the center it felt like of
like a lot of like live streaming like
when um meerkat came out we used to do
these things called marathons where we
would stream for 24 hours and it was
like and then Bitcoin came out and we
were mining Bitcoin in 2012 and 13. like
it was like in the center of a lot of
like interesting stuff and at that
period in San Francisco it felt magical
Uber was just coming out and like it was
just all this crazy stuff that was going
on like we would um remember how Uber
would do like the get 20 credit yes like
these guys were building these like this
technology that that created like a
referral scheme and we were collecting
like a million dollars in Uber credit
and we would just eat lunch for free
like we would do all this crazy stuff it
was like the center of everything it
felt like and so and then covet happened
in San Francisco went away and San
Francisco was already getting a little
bit corporate leading up to that but now
San Francisco it's got all these AI
nerds and then there's this beautiful
article written about how these hacker
houses are coming back and how it's like
the center of an AI world and two years
ago when covet hit
before that I used to tell everyone if
you have an idea for Tech to just go to
San Francisco and just be a freak for a
little while and then eventually move
away but like put in your time there and
then covet hit and I was like dude just
it's not even worth it it's dead now if
you're into AI I think you should pack
your bags and go to San Francisco and
hang out with all these people because
it feels like it's the center and it is
happening again it feels like it's like
San Francisco in 2008 you know like
where the Web 2.0 is just starting to
take off so anyway it feels magical
there I'm going actually going there
tomorrow
um but a lot of that stuff I think is
happening right now and I'm very eager
to see what these young guys come up
with what are you going to do
my wife has to go for work and I'm just
gonna go hang out uh with her uh but I
want to like I'm gonna I'm gonna go and
like walk around Alamo Square or park
because there's like these AI meetups
like in the park and I just want to like
this sounds so weird but I just want to
be around the young people man I just no
I love the youngins dude listen I I will
tell you one thing if uh uh if you were
to ask me like what's one of the uh
realizations uh that I came to over uh
over the last year so actually there's
two and then uh if I tell you two
realizations that I've learned over the
last couple years you have to tell me
too the first is easy life versus hard
life so uh there's this whole idea of
like there's certain geographies certain
places you can live and it's a much
harder life sometimes that's weather
sometimes that's like traffic and
transportation sometimes that's uh
economic situation whatever and then
there's certain places you can move and
just like literally by being in that
geography it's easier right so whether
it's like the easiest one to know
there's certain uh hard weather
situations certain easy weather
situations and I think that sometimes
people get energy from being in easy or
hard situations and both planet and I
like came to the conclusion like we're
like hard life people right we actually
don't like super super easy
um kind of like no stress like the
stress gives us energy to some degree so
that's one realization the second is uh
as you know your career progresses and
you become more successful and you get a
bigger uh kind of network and all these
things you start getting invited to all
these like quote unquote uh um hyper
successful or like really really rich uh
people like events whether they're
dinners or whatever
and uh when I'm [__] pointless like
there's still dude when I moved to Miami
there's a group of people I love these
people but what they do is they all come
together and they have dinner like all
the time right and they like literally
like twice a week and so they would like
constantly keep inviting me and I would
go and then like eventually I realized I
was like man I like hanging out with you
guys but I like hanging out with you
like once a week or once every other
week I really really like hanging out
with all the young people because that's
where I'm getting tons of new ideas
that's where I'm getting a lot of energy
from like all that type of stuff and so
I came to this realization that like
people over index on the heroes and they
under index on the people who are
younger than them who think differently
who have new technologies Etc and so
once you like realize that and you're
and you're like I want to hang out with
more young people then you start to
change your behavior you start to go to
different things you start to do things
where you can be around those people
rather than just like the older rich
people and so it's so funny because like
if I was telling my like 25 year old
self that I'd be like shut up like find
all the rich people like go learn what
they're doing whatever right and so like
I think different points in your life
also or different times of who you want
to spend time with what are your two
realizations that you've learned over
the last couple years the first one is a
little bit easy but I used to read like
every Business book you could think of
and I would try to read like a book a
week and then I realized I'm not going
to read any more business books so now I
only read fiction or I read um history I
think I could I learned more by reading
a historical biography or something
about history than I do reading about a
business book I try not to read any
business books
um the second thing is somewhat similar
so I used to at the hustle we owned this
conference business called hustlecon
where we would get speakers of startups
to come our startup Founders would come
and speak and they would like tell the
story about finding the company and I
would do this little trick where I would
tell someone if they had to speak at
three I go you got to be there by noon
because we have to do sound check mic
check
we didn't have a mic check there was no
mic check it was already set up but I
had this green room set up and it was
really just my trick to like hang out
with them and be in the room with like
five other the speakers and they would
be like for example we had like Wade
Foster the founder of zapier the founder
of Casper Casey neistat Tucker Max the
founders of wework like a lot of these
companies that are like pretty big and
successful we had them and I would just
hang out in a room with them
and I would do like what I do and I
would just start asking questions and
get just get them to talk and I would
throw something out there and like I
remember like
these founders of companies that had
multiple billion dollar exits they were
like fearful like they were like one guy
was like I'm afraid to fire this person
who's my CFO because of the
confrontation
or there was like pay all the woman who
started class pass which was like the
darling at the time I had to like she
was like pacing back and forth afraid to
talk in front of 2 000 people and I
remember she was like very nervous I was
like hey you want to talk about it or
the founder of OkCupid and now the he
was the CEO of uh I think match Sam
yeagen he the same way he was I remember
him being nervous and I just would hear
all these people like they would explain
like behind the scenes stuff they would
never talk about in public and I had the
realization
that only a couple of them are
significantly smarter than me and have a
high a higher IQ like we had the founder
of grammarly Max backstage and I
remember thinking like we're not the
same you and I are different you're just
smarter than me you have more horsepower
but then I would have these other people
like the founders of wework and Casper
and I remember thinking like
you know like you're 20 times wealthier
than me but you're not 20 times smarter
than me like we're in the same ballpark
you're just
pretty brave you know you just like did
the damn thing and that's when I learned
that IQ matters so I think Jeff Bezos
and Elon I I think they really are just
smarter than everyone else or most
others but there's a lot of people that
have a whole lot of money we're talking
billions but they're maybe a little bit
charismatic or they're just a bold and
they just went ahead and did the damn
thing but they have massive massive
doubts and I remember putting my heroes
on a pedestal and I got to hang out with
them and I'm like oh dude you have all
the same anxieties I have you just have
put yourself in a really cool situation
where you have to succeed and
it kind of changed my thinking to where
I just now I believe I can do anything I
want it's just a matter or not anything
but most anything I I can't create Tesla
but I can create a substantial amount of
money I can create a certain life for
myself if I act bold and um follow
through with certain things and that
gave me a ton of confidence and I see
that with Hampton you know like like we
have people that like cry in the
meetings and I'm like dude you're my
hero what are you doing and I'm like oh
you're just human like we all have these
similar amounts of insecurity and that
in doing that it gave me a huge amount
of confidence and a huge amount of like
it's okay to be afraid that's a normal
part of this process but I have to do it
anyway this is just part of the process
of creating art is to have self-doubt
that I suck and that this sucks but this
is just a normal process and a normal
feeling and that normalized those
feelings and it normalized success so
hanging out with people in Hampton
hanging out with the people at hustlecon
with you my successful friends people
think of us from the outside just like I
would think of people from and outside
of like well they are different they
have a club and it's it's like well yeah
we kind of do have a club but
it's very attainable like to have a
substantial amount of success and be
quote normal you know what I mean dude
confidence is one of the biggest
competitive advantages in the world and
the secret to confidence is like it
takes a really really special person to
be confident in an area where they're
not surrounded by other people who can
do the thing but damn is it easy to be
confident when all of your friends are
super successful and like it's just like
that's what we do right I think I
normalize it it's like dude it's like
Jamaica like Jamaica is a small ass
country
why do they just crush the 100 meter
dash like you know like in America we
have these awesome athletes as well but
they're killing it when they're smaller
well because they just like grew up
expecting that they could be good at
this and I think that like you see that
in sports I think you see it in business
you see it in art you see it in a lot of
things where like you know why was Keith
Haring and um what's the uh Basquiat and
then
um I forget the what's the Andy Warhol
like they all were a crew like what
magic came out of that or NWA you look
at NWA easy Dr Dre uh and then like
Snoop eventually came along Tupac like
all these guys they were a crew and they
all like elevated each other to like
they were like 23 year old kids and they
just invented like this whole genre of
culture changing music like what is it
about like creating a crew where you egg
each other on and do something special
and I once I realized that like there's
a reason why greatness typically comes
from a certain area over and over and
over again and you've got to throw
yourself in the mix once I realized that
I got a ton of confidence I love that
that's my one of the best insights
somebody's selling this podcast isn't
alone time uh tell everyone where we can
send them if they want to check out
Hampton and apply
go to joinhampton.com
um I'm on Twitter the Sam par
um yeah uh We've launched uh well I
launched it in July but now it's
officially live as of March 28th but go
there and apply and if you fit the
criteria we interview you
all right Sam we could do this literally
for hours in the last two days you and I
think I've done four hours of podcast uh
and we still have plenty to talk about
so we'll do this again in the future
that was good I hope I got a good uh a
few good Clips out of this I I think
that uh also anyone who uh is watching
this after you've subscribed to our
Channel you should go fulfill the uh my
first million Gentlemen's Agreement you
should go over to their Gentleman's
Agreement the lady's understanding watch
those stuff surge baby to the moon go
subscribe to the my first million uh
YouTube page as well Sam I appreciate it
we'll do it again
thank you